JEFFREY CARDILLE: OK.
Hi everyone.
Thanks For coming here today,
and thanks for tuning in.
My name is Jeff Cardille.
I'm a professor at the
University of Montreal in the
Geography Department.
And I'll be talking with you
today about a Master's project
that we have just finished up in
the last few months called
GeoSearch, which is a new
virtual globe application for
the submission, sharing, and
visualization of point-based
ecological data.
The work that I'm presenting
here is not really so much my
own as Rodolphe Gonzales'.
He's a student who was
co-supervised by Lael Parrott,
my colleague in geography,
and myself.
And Rodolphe really is
responsible for both
conceiving of, developing in
most of the cases, and
managing, in addition, the
work that you see here.
There are also some huge
contributions by the people
you see on the right side
of your screen there.
Gael Deest, who did database
development, Caroline
Gaudreau, who did
interface work.
Benoit [INAUDIBLE], who gave
us the ability to introduce
data to our network.
Casey Brown and Jean-Francois
Marsan, who came on in the
last few months.
And of course, all of this is
built on the development in
Google Earth and Google Maps,
the prefuse library of
visualization technologies,
and World Wind.
I mention there are also the
students of my course 6352,
which I'll talk about for a few
minutes at the very beginning.
So this is the first time I've
ever been recorded, I think,
for a talk in my life.
It's for sure the first
time I've ever been
recorded for YouTube.
And as a result I've gotten lots
and lots of advice from
everyone from our babysitter
to people at the day care.
My wife has some ideas, my
mom has some ideas about
what I should do.
And they center around trying
to make the video viral.
So I've had suggestions to rap
the entire presentation.
So if I had some good rapping
skills, that might be
something we'd do.
Also animating a dancing baby
seems to be a very popular way
to get a lot of hits
on your site.
Let's see, anything with Star
Wars in it seems to be quite
popular, whether it's waving
a sword around or
making my own videos.
And of course, anything
that has to do with
Evolution of Dance.
So if it were possible for me
to do Evolution of Dance,
perhaps combining that with a
Diet Coke and Mentos, while
rapping, or possibly having a
dancing baby rapping the Star
Wars theme, while dancing around
and doing our Diet
Cokes, that's what I would do.
So I'm not going to
do that, for sure.
But the main advice
that I got from
everyone is to be yourself.
So hopefully, some
of that will come
through during this talk.
So as I say, we'll talk about
the course, first of all,
because that really is the
source of all of the work that
you see here.
And then second, talk about
GeoSearch, the globe-based
data browser.
Third is the Sustainable Forest
Management Network
Social Network Browser,
which we developed as
part of this package.
Third, looking at project
locations.
And fourth, looking at journal
article study sites.
So I mentioned this course
because, really, it's the
foundation for all of the
work that you see here.
It's a practical graduate
seminar that I developed when
I arrived at the University of
Montreal three years ago.
And this seminar focuses on the
capabilities and recent
developments in Google
Maps and World
Wind and Google Earth.
I mentioned that it's a
practical seminar, and the
reason is that we have a
practical component.
It's one of the few graduate
courses where we have three
hours in lab each week.
And some of the labs that
we've developed for this
course, you can see there
written on the screen.
We have two for Google Maps.
We introduce these graduate
students to
MyMaps and shared editing.
In the earlier days of the
course, three years ago, there
was no MyMaps so that lab
in particular has
changed quite a bit.
Second, you can see three
ways to embed your
map on a web page.
Students learn that in their
second or third week.
Then we have a second module.
The students do a small project
in Google Maps making
a mashup of some sort.
For the second module,
we look at the
Introduction to World Wind.
We've developed a lab for
that, looking at the New
Orleans data provided by
the World Wind system.
Data with World Wind looking
at web mapping servers,
vector, and rectified
raster data.
And that's for the World
Wind component.
For the third component, looking
at Google Earth, we
have written labs looking
at KML and Google Earth.
And in particular, in that one,
what we do is we have
students pick apart an
existing KML file.
The KML file that we use is
one created by National
Geographic for elephant poaching
several years ago.
It's got a real wide range
of things that KML
is capable of doing.
And so students pick that KML
apart, change it a little bit
for their own purposes
as part of that lab.
You can see the other
labs there as well.
We have one on Yahoo Pipes and
Google SketchUp, and that's
the practical part.
For the seminar part, you can
see here that the students
collaborate throughout the
semester by annotating
websites, annotating blog
postings, talking about
mashups that exist, and looking
at the various cutting
edge things that are done with
Google Earth, Google Maps, and
World Wind.
As I said, it's a grad seminar,
and so students bring
the material to this course.
So for example, in the first
week during the morning
session, the students are asked
to look on the Google
Maps Mania blog for examples of
mashups related to Canada.
100 things that you can do
with Google Maps mashups,
Google Maps Mania, special
features, for example, social
networking using mashups.
And what they do under a common
user, students create a
very extensive Google notebook
annotating all of the newest
things that they have found and
brought to my course, to
our course, really.
Because they're the ones
bringing the content.
They bring this stuff, we talk
about it for three hours, it
catches me up very quickly, and
it allows them to learn, I
think, much faster than if they
were simply listening to
my lectures about what I think
these technologies can do.
So it's a grad seminar, and
everything's online, using
lots and lots of Google
technology things.
All of the student work, as I
say, there's hundreds of sites
now that are explained in Google
notebooks, one for each
of these three technologies.
All of the students' reports for
the labs and projects that
they produce are in
Google documents.
The student presentations
themselves are in Google
documents, so there's no trading
of USB keys at the
beginning of the class.
They simply upload their
presentation or work on their
presentation directly in Google
Docs, and we look at
them together through the
internet connection in the
department.
The syllabus is at Google Sites
if anyone hearing this
is interested in looking at
that, or adopting it, or in
fact, just taking the syllabus
and doing it for a
class of your own.
You can feel completely
free to do that.
The labs are in Google documents
and all the data is
available, which is a really
nice thing for teachers who
are interested in teaching
in a practical way, these
abilities, these technologies.
It is in French.
It's a French-speaking
university, but Google
Translate does a great job of
translating my broken French
and the students' fantastic
French into
any number of languages.
So as I mentioned, that's a
course that I do, and it
really is the thing that
underlies this project that
I'm about to describe to you.
The reason is that the TA for
that course is the same
Rodolphe Gonzales who had come
to me when he heard that I was
shopping around the
idea of a course.
He came to me and said,
oh, I know a little
bit about World Wind.
At that moment, I had
never heard of it.
He said Google Earth, I know
you can do things that are
more than just looking
at your house.
I thought that was a pretty
thing, so I took
him on as the TA.
And then soon after that,
I was approached by the
Sustainable Forest Management
Network, which is funded by
NSERC, the National Science
and Engineering Research
Council of Canada, which is
somewhat like the National
Science Foundation here
in the United States.
So this Sustainable Forest
Management Network is an
umbrella organization
of forest research.
And what they have done for
the last 15 or 16 years is
they have created projects,
given money for science
projects, done on the general
theme of sustainable forest
management.
And yet, at the end of their
time, at the end of this
15-year period, decade and a
half, they have, I would say,
very limited access to the data
that has been gathered as
part of their management
network.
At the beginning of this--
that goes back
to the early 1990s--
internet sharing was a
pretty rare thing.
Projects were probably not
even done in PDF, I would
think, project reports going
back all the way at the
beginning of that.
And so, there's very fragmentary
evidence of this
network and the data that this
network had gathered.
So they came to us with four big
questions, and those are
the four components that I'll
talk to you about here today.
So their first main question
is, where are data samples
located from all of the work
that we've done on our
research, and what
are their values?
Second, the basic question
of who worked with
whom in this network?
After a 15-year period it's
possible to reconstruct who
had worked with whom, and
what they had done.
Third, where were projects
located, and
what were their results?
And fourth, what journal
articles were created through
this network?
So the answer to the first
question forms the title of
this talk, GeoSearch.
The main question there is where
are samples located, and
what are their values?
Our goal is to create a set of
programs, or to really adapt
the set of programs, that take
advantage of these emerging
capabilities.
So what you see there on the
upper left is a globe
representing World Wind, which
is the virtual globe that we
embedded this data on.
Second in line, the gray form
that says By Province is a
really amazing set of Java
libraries called prefuse,
which is data visualization
techniques developed at the
University of Berkeley, if I'm
correct, by a PhD student for
his PhD work.
And the third represents
databases.
So what you can see here is our
GeoSearch application in
action here.
You can see just the
basic ability to
move the globe around.
But I think what is really the
most interesting about this
particular component is the
ability to move through this
network of information down on
the bottom using this prefuse
set of libraries.
So you can move around and
select information such as, I
think in this case, lichen
cover and other forest
information.
Show the two of them together.
And the two them are displayed
together, these two variables,
herbaceous cover and lichen
cover, on the globe.
It's possible to move around,
zoom in, and do all the
various things that you're
used to doing, with the
addition of this neat feature
of being able to view in the
third dimension of the globe,
the fourth dimension of time
as represented in the data.
So we elevate the individual
points to an elevation that
represents the date that
they were collected.
So data from 1992 is lower than
data from 1997, which is
lower from data in 2008.
You can see the large black
bar in the middle that the
cursor is moving across there.
And what that is doing, is doing
a selection of data from
a particular time, that's
a time line.
So as you can see, there's data
at two basic elevations
shown in the figure there, and
so that's data selected from
the left side of the
time diagram.
And on the right--
the eastern part of
Canada, I think--
is the data from the
other period.
So here's a little bit of a
closer view of what that data
might look like if you were
to look at it with this
mocked-up data here.
And this represents the change
in two variables.
In this case, it's dissolved
organic carbon, and dissolved
inorganic carbon taken from
a carbon simulation model
simulating the development of
carbon in lakes and its
changing concentration
throughout the year.
And what that represents is the
months of January to June,
on average, in these two
particular lakes.
So that's the combination of
these three technologies in
one, built from World Wind Java,
prefuse libraries for
moving around through the data,
and with the database
built from PostgreSQL.
So in this first go-around, this
first draft, that's one
of the main things that Rodolphe
produced as part of
his master's degree.
And it's, I think, important
to realize that it's pretty
amazing for a master's project
to have done something that's
really pretty impressive,
capable of taking in this
data, or capable, really, of
displaying data that's already
been taken in.
So data entry for us, at
the beginning, was
not the main focus.
We were really focused on
visualizing this information,
and so data entry until just a
few months ago, in fact, just
a few days ago, was
very difficult.
So even though, theoretically,
we could get data into the
shared database, it was quite
hard for anyone except a real
experienced administrator
to get data in.
So what we did was we went back
to a project that I had
begun when I was a post-doc at
the University of Quebec at
Montreal to do the same kind
of thing but in, I think, a
pre-Google Earth period.
This was in 2005.
We looked at trying to find some
way to share information
among the lake researchers in
this inter-university group of
research in limnology,
limnology being
the study of lakes.
So we had a large amount
of information.
This is another much smaller
network made of Quebec
scientists who gather
information about lakes.
And like the people in the
forest network, their data
sits in individual Excel files
on their computer.
And those computers get old,
the formats change, and the
data basically sits as
individuals, and rests as
individuals.
What we had looked to do, and
what we succeeded in beginning
at least, was to create a
framework for people to upload
data to the shared database.
At that time, there was no
shared globe ability.
There was simply the ability to
upload data to this common
database and do a simple yes/no
search with a few
ranges in order to
extract data.
So this was a data introduction,
and data
storage, and data
extraction tool.
And that's where it sat for
several years until just a
month or two ago.
What we did was to take that
and basically graft it onto
the World Wind-based GeoSearch
application that I told you
about just a few minutes ago.
And so now we've introduced
the ability to have easy
uploading of data.
You can add sites.
We've changed it from being
lake-focused into being able
to gather information or accept
information for any
sort of point-based site,
with the latitude,
longitude, and site name.
You can also add data.
The system has a pretty
sophisticated parser for
understanding the different
names that people can call the
same effective bit of data.
So in Quebec in particular,
where English and French are
both spoken, I might call
something dissolved organic
carbon, but the French acronym
for that is not DOC but COD.
And so this system allows for
that ability to switch back
and forth, or to, in effect,
interpret intelligently what
it is the user is trying input,
by asking a pretty
smart series of questions, and
building intelligence over
time, and what data rests
in the database.
In the last few weeks or so, I
guess, we have introduced the
ability to do a simple search
in Google Maps.
You can see that on the right
side of your screen.
And by choosing among the data
sets, we can click on that
little menu item
that says DOC.
When you do that, a slider comes
up and it allows you to
move back and forth between the
different values that you
might want of DOC to pull
out of the database.
So in this case, the user has
slid the sliders left and
right to ask for data between
2.8 to 10.2, and when they hit
Refresh Map, they can see where
the samples that fit
those criteria were selected
in this data set.
Meanwhile, that data exists in
the three-dimensional browser
in the virtual globe that
you saw as well.
So that's the first of our
four driving questions.
For the next five minutes or
so, just maybe six minutes,
I'll tell you about the
following three in pretty
quick succession of detail.
And so, the second.
Who worked with whom
in this network?
That's another basic question
that the Sustainable Forest
Management Network
was interested in
reporting, or in recording.
And they asked us if
we were capable of
keeping track of that.
And in fact, we were.
Here you can see a very
roughly-animated view of the network.
I'll zoom in on that
in just a minute.
And what that shows is, sort
of in a constellation form,
shows who has worked
with whom.
There are hundreds of
researchers shown on this
slide that we see there.
And I'll tell you about the
panels that we see on the
right in detail in
just a minute.
What this allows us to do
is to basically click on
individuals and see the network
from just their
perspective.
So in this case I've clicked on
this person, David, and we
can see all of the people
who he has worked with.
Depending on the version of the
software, we can allow it
to look two levels deep, or
three levels deep in order to
see who the people worked with,
who he worked with.
And we can basically move
through this network, seeing
the network from the perspective
of individual
researchers.
And so what you see here on the
right is what this thing
looks like in action.
The prefuse library moves people
around, it moves their
nodes around based on physics
principles, I think, if I
understand it right.
You can still interact with
the system though as it's
doing that.
We can move back and forth, we
can click and move between
individual researchers and see
the network from their
perspective.
So again, this is the
Sustainable Forest Management
Network social browser.
So it allows us to see who these
individuals are, and who
they have worked with.
We also have a feature there on
the left in the middle, you
can see it's called
a business card.
It's a bit hard to read with
this particular color that we
have, for people who work,
I think in the
government in this case.
So you can see the color of the
nodes, and the color of
this business card represents
where they came from and who
they work--
their basic category.
Whether they're from academia,
or non-governmental work, or
industry, government,
aboriginal, or if we didn't
have the information, we gave
them, I think, a gray color.
So the point here, though, is
that you can click on the
business card and learn more
about the researcher.
So when you click on the
business card, what we do is
we issue a very standard Google
search, searching for
the name of the researcher who
you clicked on, and their
university or their
organization.
I think we also enter forest
management as well.
And as any great Google search
does, it gives us a long list
of links, some of which are
more relevant than others.
In this case, just getting ready
for this talk, I was
able to learn quite a bit
about this particular
researcher, Dr. Ed Johnson.
And not only the project that he
had worked on and his main
homepage, which was the first
list, but also this really
interesting ecology education
project that
he works on as well.
So it's possible to learn not
only what they have done in
this particular forest network,
but more broadly,
what it is that they've
worked on.
This is, again, Java using the
prefuse library, with a thing
called a tree ML, tree
Mark-up Language.
And it's basically set up to
say, David works in academia
and Jane works in academia.
David works with Jane, and
Jane works with Jim.
And from that is produced that
large network that you see.
So that's the second
of these four.
I'll move real quickly
through the last two.
So we also are curious where
projects were located, and
what are their results.
Well there is a reporting
requirement, and was a
reporting requirement, in the
Sustainable Forest Management
for producing project reports.
But those project reports,
they're basically stored on
their server as project
PR-145-2004, and they're
really pretty hard to get to.
So what we did was to produce
this KML that's suitable for
looking at in Google Maps that
shows us where the study sites
of the Sustainable Forest
Management projects were.
And this is a real simple thing
done with about 100
hours or so of an undergraduate
technician's
time, reading project reports
very, very quickly and trying
to pull out the relevant
information to
show them on a map.
When you click on it, we use the
Google Spreadsheet Mapper
to show in a real
nicely-formatted structure,
the main information that
we have found in
those project reports.
So you can see, here's the title
of it, who the authors
of that project were, a little
excerpt from the beginning.
You can also click on the PDF
of the project report, which
takes you into the window in the
database that's currently
managed by the Sustainable
Forest Management Network.
And we can also do a Google
search like you already saw
for the individual researcher.
So the way that this was done
was actually quite simple.
And I'd encourage other
organizations to do this.
It didn't take very
long at all.
What we did was we went to
the Network's website and
downloaded 200 or 300
project reports.
And then read those reports,
looking for maps of the study
sites, or looking for, as you
can see there in the Methods
section, it says the 8,000
square kilometer area was
located in Prince Albert
Provincial Park at the
following latitude
and longitude.
So that's where we located
that project to be.
We then pasted the executive
summary and some other
interesting things, pasted all
that stuff into Excel in a
very carefully-formatted way,
because the goal was to put it
into the Google Spreadsheet
Mapper.
If you know what that does, then
you know it's just really
pretty amazing.
If you don't know what it does,
what it allows you do is
to create these
nicely-structured info bullets
that you see on the left.
So we took them from the Google
Spreadsheet Mapper,
produced the KML file, stored
that KML file to Google Sites,
and that KML file is suitable
for introducing into Google
Maps in simple ways
that you can--
I guess you could read
the labs for the
course to do that.
You can also look at in a
typical way in Google Earth.
And also, we're probably going
to embed this on the main data
server in a few weeks.
So that's how we located where
projects were, which is a big
advance over where things had
been, and the way things had
been stored in the past at the
Sustainable Forest Management
Network data site.
Finally, I'll talk about what
journal articles were created
through this network.
That's one of the big measures
of the success of a large,
long-term network like this.
And what we did was we took
a slightly different
perspective for this.
Again, we scraped through the
information that we could find
at the network site.
But in this case, we created
a collaborative MyMap.
And I'll tell you more about
that in just a second.
You can see the letters of the
alphabet there floating in the
bay in the northern
part of Canada and
that's a false location.
That's just designed for
individual researchers to be
able to grab their letter, a
letter that represents their
article, and drag it across
the country to where
the study site was.
Because we read the articles,
we knew where the sites
actually had been where these
articles have been done.
But we wanted to introduce this
idea for researchers of
the ability for them to interact
with this over a long
period of time.
We currently have it stored
as a public map.
It's been viewed many thousands
of times, which kind
of surprised me when
I noticed that.
But it seems like it's a useful
doorway into this work
that has been done.
So when you click on it, you get
something similar to what
you've already seen, with the
addition of the little item
that says Search for Article
at Google Scholar.
If you click on that, you see
the results of the Google
Scholar search.
And that gives, of course, not
only the article itself and
access to the article, if that
access is warranted, but also
articles that are related.
So in my case, I was able to
use this to find several
articles that were really
interesting to me on a couple
of different topics.
So the way that was done
is quite similar.
We went to the Network website
and looked at this PDF
bibliography of articles,
which was basically a
statement of the articles and
their citations of the
articles that were done over
a five or so year period.
Put that through Google Scholar,
found those, made an
end node database, read all
of those articles-- again,
Jean-Francois did an amazing
job of that.
Put them into Excel, took them
through the Spreadsheet
Mapper, but then imported that
KML into MyMaps that now is
editable by people who have
the password for this
particular map.
So authors can move their
points around.
So to summarize, there are four
main things that I've
talked about here.
The first is our approach to
looking at data samples, where
the data samples are located
in this, for me, large, but
depending on the scale,
medium-size
network of science research.
Where those samples
are located, and
what are their values?
Second, who worked with
whom in this network?
I think there's a real neat
solution to that, that also
gives additional value for
being able to find the
researchers in the network.
And third and fourth, these
location-based ways of
interacting or at least viewing
the database of
project locations, project
reports, and journal articles.
So like a lot of projects, there
are a lot of limitations
to it, I would say.
And several things that we
really hope to do with it in
the future.
The limitations are substantial,
I would say.
It's a first draft of nearly
everything, so the program's
crashed from time to time.
Not the Google Maps part.
But the work that we've done
on the globe, and moving
around between prefuse and the
globe works pretty well.
But at the moment, it's still
download-only, and so we'd
like to take that and eventually
make that into an
applet and store that on a web
page, so that we don't have to
encourage users to download a
new version every time we
correct a few bugs.
I would say also, it's
not quite yet
ready for massive scale-up.
There are some things in the
design that we would like to
change, and we'll be doing that
in the first few months
of next year.
So we're interested in partners,
whether it's
organizational or just
individuals, to try to think
these things through.
As I said, this is basically one
student's masters project,
and it's an extremely ambitious
project that I think
was really successful.
And so for example, we like to
find out how we should best
make this transfer between the
server and the client to be
not just downloaded all at
once, but as needed.
I know Google Earth does that
really well with their tiling,
and so we may try to adopt
something like that as well
for ourselves.
We're also interested in anyone
who hears or sees this
and is interested in testing
usability of this system.
This is basically done as a
group of 5 or 10 individuals
making their best decisions.
And also any creative
ideas on next steps.
So you can see the link to the
websites where you could learn
more about this if you're
interested.
And just to summarize again, the
idea here is talking about
this new virtual globe
application for submitting,
and sharing, and
visualizing our
point-based ecological data.
Again this is the work mainly
of Rodolphe Gonzales, who we
co-directed, Lael and I. And
there's a lot of work that is
buried in the details here by
Gael, and Carolyn, and Benoit,
and Casey, and Jean-Francois.
So again, thank you,
very much.
And I appreciate the time.